zainab Adams lives in the city of tamale
600 kilometers north of Ghana's Capital
Accra
three of her children are sick with
measles and she suspects her fourth is
two she's left her business to visit
them in hospital
this is really stressful I had to lock
up my shop to be with them at the
hospital and the little money I have is
what is spent on their medication this
shouldn't have happened I tried to get
all my children vaccinated against these
preventable diseases but was
unsuccessful why should the country even
run out of vaccines for children
zainab's children are among scorers
who've Fallen ill since October last
year during an outbreak of measles in
the North
the United Nations and Ghana's Health
Minister say children have not died from
the disease in the country for nearly 20
years now five are suspected to have
died since the start of 2023. many
health workers say that could have been
prevented by vaccination
we realized that over 80 percent of the
patience that we got between last year
and now
um have not received a immunization
either they they have not received
anything or they received just a single
dose
six standard childhood vaccines are made
available in Ghana through the UN and
the global vaccine Alliance gavi the
government-funded vaccines including for
measles ran out it blames an inflation
rate of more than 50 percent
our role is also to reach out to our
various offices across the globe to see
whether some friendly countries can land
some of these vaccines to to countries
so that they feel the Gap Ghana is among
many African States whose vaccination
programs were brought to a standstill
during the pandemic the government
acknowledges there are shortages but
says it's managed to get some new
deliveries
but they've come too late for zainab's
children and she can only wait and hope
they recover
Colin Baker Al Jazeera